What you'll notice here is that I gave you a quiz
before telling you how to actually determine whether
the timing of inputs is important for a particular software under test,
and that was deliberate because I wanted to get you to think about the issues
but also because there aren't really any great hard and fast answers here,
so let's talk about this a little bit more.
Basically what you want to do to figure out if timing matters for the inputs
for the software under test is think about its specification.
Think about what it's trying to do.
Think about its requirements, and also look at the source code for the software,
and you want to look for things like timeouts, things like timed sleeps,
and basically values or computations
that depend on the time at which things happen.
If you see any of that, then it's strongly possible
that you're going to need to take time into account while testing the software,
and that means, for example, delivering some inputs to the software under test very quickly,
delivering other inputs rapidly, and seeing how the software responds.